i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is joe circio and you
may know me from this meme have you ever
had a dream
that
that you um you had this all started in
the year 1999 i was five years old my
favorite thing to do when i was a kid
was watch fantasy action stuff you know
dragon ball z power rangers i liked all
the disney stuff hercules came out
around the summer before i went into
kindergarten and i definitely watched it
a lot i really like the soundtrack
especially zero2hero that was that was a
tune that still is a tune
one day my mom reached out to me and
said do you want to be in a movie there
was a few schools that they filmed that
for this hbo production the reason my
elementary school got picked in part was
because the production manager their kid
was in my class or in one of the
kindergarten classes at first i really
had no idea what this production was
about they had repurposed one of the
bigger classrooms to look sort of like a
nursery there's lights there's cameras i
i picked up pretty early on that it was
about bedtime stories and rituals
because that was what the people
interviewing us were interested in so
they were asking us guiding questions to
that effect the red sweater the haircut
that was like all my mom she really
wanted me to get on tv they were asking
us a bunch of questions there wasn't
anyone that i would consider a rival per
se but there were kids that were even
better at getting the attention of the
producers and based on a promise i made
to my mother in the car this morning
that i was definitely going to get on tv
i kind of had a sense that time was
running out and i didn't get as much
talking time as compared with the other
kids on my panel and then they asked me
about dreams i remember this one scene
from hercules where hercules searches
out for pan who's danny devito's
character he doesn't want to train
anybody anymore and he's a failure so
that's when hercules comes in and tries
to persuade him about a dream have you
ever had a dream i've had a dream that i
wanted so much that i could do anything
and once he said that it really
resonated with pan and pan said okay
fine i'm going to train you and the rest
is history so that was when i came in
with my hail mary speech about dreams
suffice to say i didn't i didn't come
even close to what what hercules had to
say about dreams have you ever had a
dream
that
that you um you had you you what you
could you do you
i'm thinking a little bit slower than
how i'm talking which tends to happen so
you you could do so you
you
you could you
but i'm kind of hoping that if i have
the beginning and the end of that speech
down everything else was going to kind
of fall into place
you want you want him to do you so much
you could do anything so as everyone
likes to point out my signature lean
back and smile is just like ah i totally
nailed that if memory serves me the
reaction the room
was very deadpan and professional by the
interviewers so they just kind of let me
talk like oh okay yeah dream sure like
you know run with that and oh you know
we're we're all set here joe like that
was great you know
good job i i wasn't too sure whether
they were going to use anything that i
said
but i definitely felt like what i said
was really really compelling i didn't
hear much follow follow-up about the
movie until it was time to go see the
premiere in new york so it was this big
fancy hall that hbo booked out and they
invited all the kids that had a speaking
part it was kind of a red carpet moment
and i enjoyed watching the production
and all my other friends that talked
then and then my part is an outtake at
the end of the movie the whole audience
is laughing at me with the benefit of
hindsight i think they were more so
laughing with me but i didn't feel that
the time and i actually was so upset
with the producers i actually blamed
them i thought that they had manipulated
the film in some way to make it look
like i stammered i didn't even accept
that i had stammered on on the camera
which isn't true but it's just to say i
wasn't necessarily a good sport about
that especially because for the rest of
my childhood and early teenage years
that was always going to be shown at
most family reunions anyone in my family
that wanted to get a vhs or a dvd of
that documentary got it and they all
reveled in my part and i just kind of
want that swept under the rug i want to
get past it and it was more or less
buried and then one of my friends
reaches out to me in high school and he
says dude i can't believe it um somebody
circulated the clip of your video
eventually someone put that on youtube
and it started to get momentum it was in
the tens of thousands to the hundreds of
thousands of views the last time i
looked on youtube at the original post
it's about 76 million views and that's
just youtube so now i want to take this
opportunity to say what i meant to say
that time
have you ever had a dream
that was so
palpable
so
crucial
to your goals and your aspirations
that you would do
absolutely anything to accomplish it
i've had that dream
and this is my story
[Music]